hey it's Tom and Jenny from 13 o'clock
and we have a couple of announcements to
make yeah we'll watch Tom what's going
on well first thing we have put up a
patreon page and we're going to talk
about that some in the episode but I
just wanted to up get it out here now I
wanted to make this announcement before
this episode because we have left
project entertainment network yeah we
left on good terms though yeah so and we
recorded this episode before we knew
that we were going to leave so that's
why I kind of wanted to put this in
front because there's still like a lot
of project entertainment shoutouts and
you should totally still go listen to
project Entertainment Network and their
other shows and go to their patreon and
although there's kind of stuff like we
normally say there's no yeah there is no
bad blood between us it's totally fine
what happened is we slowly kind of
evolved into more of a youtube show than
a podcast it came from a podcast but
really all of our action and all of our
interaction with the public comes from
our YouTube show yeah most of it is
YouTube listeners and we kind of wanted
to concentrate more on that yeah and
when we opened a patreon account up it
put some conflicts yeah we would have a
conflict of interest with Project
Entertainment Network because they have
they are running a patreon to pay for
all of their podcasts and rather than
step on their toes and you know take
money away from their pod cat we thought
we would just go our own way and go into
yeah we I thought we had permission to
open a patreon but it turns out it's
just a misunderstanding
and you know we're allowed a personal
patreon yeah but not a 13 o'clock
podcast and and really when once we kind
of looked at the numbers and saw where
everything was coming from it was more
on our advantage to go our own way so
yeah we talked to our mod Rose Amelia
who runs the project entertainment
Network we talked to him this morning
and we decided that we were just going
to take 13 o'clock totally independent
and so there wouldn't be any more
conflict of interest with the patreon
and all that other kind of thing so
that's what we decided to do now if you
are listening to our show on YouTube
then this will probably not really
affect you in the slightest there will
still be new shows up coming up every
Tuesday just like always
the only difference will be there will
be less commercials basically so good
for you now if you are listening to us
on just the audio version of the podcast
then probably you will have a slightly
different experience what I'm doing
right now I'm not super savvy about it
about all of this podcasts hosting and
stuff like that but I do have a blog
that I've been posting to the entire
time that the show has been up and it's
at 13 o'clock podcast wordpress.com and
there is a feed there where you should
be able to download the audio version
hopefully I have them posted on
archive.org so you can get them from
there also and so although it may be
like a little sketchy for a few weeks
until I get everything sorted out until
I you know get everything together about
who's downloading where from what so we
might get behind on a couple but it
should be okay so if you want the audio
version only and not the YouTube then
just go to 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and the audio file will be
there or you can download it from
archive.org we have a page they're
called 13 o'clock podcast also you can
get it from there so you should still be
able to get it if you're on the audio
version like I said YouTube it shouldn't
make any difference at all it'll still
be new shows up every Tuesday and there
won't be any difference there so
hopefully this will be a positive move
for us and like I said we have just put
up a patreon page and we talked about it
some on this episode so I won't really
like you know flog a dead horse or
anything like that but you should
definitely should go to
patreon.com/scishow to 9 o'clock podcast
and we have some kind of cool extra
stuff up there at the moment and we're
going to put some more extra content up
there as the week's go on so please
check that out and enjoy this episode of
13 o'clock thank you very much Tom had
to leave that's why he wasn't on the
last couple minutes in case you wondered
in 1945 on the slopes of nyan hill an
event took place which brought
witchcraft into the national dailies a
particularly gruesome murder was
committed which soon became known as the
witchcraft
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
and it's us again welcome to episode 49
murder by witchcraft yeah
with a question mark because they're not
really sure but you know so the premise
of the show is distant people
successfully kill somebody else using
witchcraft no it's not so much that it
was just that these two particular
murders that took place in England in
the 1940s particularly in the Midlands
the motive for them has been presumed
that maybe it has something to do with
witchcraft that they were killed in like
an occult ritual rizal not to call
murders
yeah or you know ostensibly occult
murders I don't know if they really work
all right let's do let's do some
housekeeping guys got to talk about
patreon yes this is big news I was
actually going to wait until episode 50
to put up the patreon page and make the
announcement but you know what the hell
we went ahead and put up a patreon page
that's right there's some bonus material
on there yeah we have already put up you
know four five ten and twenty visit ears
and for the $5 and up we're going to put
like a bunch of patreon only posts and
stuff like that we already have a couple
things up there we put up like a half
hour thing about to talk about cheesy
music documentaries yeah I put up about
a five minute teaser for my new true
crime book the phasers villain which is
coming out you know so we're going to
keep every you know a few days I want to
put up some more you have this material
we have cool bonus stuff on there yeah
that's like talking about various other
topics and and so far we have three
patrons so I want to give a shout out to
them runs dan Miken in the UK he's a
heavy lifter then there's somebody just
goes by the name of M s pretty much a
heavy lifter too then there's Veronica
Vader
thanks Veronica now we want to tell you
something the minimum lead that we have
listed in the page still is five but it
doesn't have to be five you can send a
dollar yeah it'll it'll take any amount
any amount of good any amount of group
and honestly any amount that you pledge
will get you access to our patreon all
the bonus stuff yeah yeah now at 20
we're going to send our heavy lifters uh
some merch yeah it'll be things like
shirts t-shirts signed stuff like maybe
some autographed books things like that
knickers so tomorrow we clear a few
magnets yeah we have all this card stuff
like that but it's all just it's all
just
depends on what we have at what time
they'll probably get something sent out
every three months or so yeah that's
what I was planning on I'm going to kind
of keep to a schedule like if so if you
are in the tier that gets merchandise
I'm going to send stuff out four times a
year it's going to be September 15 to
December 15th March 15th and June 15
that's what I'm going to do the mail up
that's what I'm planning
yeah we're just going to do online
hangout fit yes it starts at the $5 tier
right or attending $10 $10 to the $10 of
Geology okay okay so we're going to
invite we're going to do like monthly
I'm either going to do a monthly Google
hangout or alternate Google hangout and
watch it on patreon I'll probably do
those like the last weekend of the month
starting at the end of August so however
many $10 enough patrons we have at that
point then you know you'll get an invite
we'll try to figure out what day and
time is best for everybody and all that
kind of stuff so a big thanks to our
first three payers yes and if anybody
wants to give us some money and go to
patreon.com/scishow and there we are
with our cute little video yeah and
predict for our podcast people anything
you can contribute more than well and I
would also like to mention want to keep
the show going then you know yeah it's
good yeah it's going to help us you know
through the show and improve the show to
get better equipment and all that kind
of stuff I also want to mention projects
Entertainment Network they're all as
always doing a great job they also have
a patreon which is at patreon.com slash
project and net so if you want to go
give them a couple bucks and that would
be greatly appreciated too because that
helps our show and it helps all the
other shows that are on the network with
us which are all quite awesome yeah they
usually use that money for promotional
stuff to help advertise the entire
network
yeah and they and they also buy
advertising for our show and various
other formats and things like that so
that really does help us out as well as
helped out all the other shows on the
network so you know if you want to go
and help them out too that would be
awesome and what else are we going to
okay let's mention again a spooky Empire
which is coming up the weekend before
Halloween the 27th 28th and the 29th of
October and we will both be there all
three days and we will be on several of
the panels we're doing the sick and
twisted panel on Friday night we're
actually kind of
charge of s you know we're going to be
on various other panels over the weekend
we will be out at the table we will be
selling books will be interacting with
the public so if you're in the Orlando
Florida area the weekend before
Halloween then come out and meet us and
hang out with us and drink with us you
know it'll be fun okay unseen hands
doing well ratings have been really good
on it yeah I've been getting a lot of
really good reviews recently the
audiobooks pretty popular
yeah and say this faithless Valens
coming soon yeah talk about a bunch of
unsolved murders yeah eventually it's
going to be three volumes
Volume one should be out I'm trying to
get it out before spooky Empire yes so
I'll have some copies there a lot of
tell people there are a lot of unsolved
murder fans out there in the market so I
think this is going to be this series
yeah people don't and actually the two
cases were discussing on the show today
are in are going to be in this volume
okra so because it happened in the 40s
this first volume is going to be
covering like creepy unsolved murders
from like 1900 to 1959 I think it's the
cop here yeah and then the second volume
will be you know later years and then
the third volume would be up to the
present day
and 13 o'clock and minutes are the
channels growing you know it's just
starting I think that's 25 something
like that we'd really appreciate it if
you guys would subscribe to that one
also yeah we've so far we have 11 videos
up I just put one up a couple of days
ago yeah it was a creepiest abandoned
places on earth
yeah if you've got a big old Smart TV
it's cool to put that thing on and just
let them run through all of them got
that Pat hypnotic music and all those
graphics going look cool yeah and I also
want to say shout out to a lot of the I
get a lot of my music clips and sound
effects from freesound.org all the users
who stuff I used I put their names in
the credits of the YouTube videos just
to give them a little bit of credit I
mean I usually layer them and slow them
down or speed them up or do various
things to kind of make it sound original
you know so so I'm not just wiping out
of people's music
so anyway go subscribe to 13 o'clock in
minutes that's our channel I'm going to
try and put up at least two videos a
month that's what I'm shooting for and
hopefully I fall you guys go and
subscribe and you know that'll be cool
all right so we got most of the way I
think yeah rotoma bullet our
justification
yeah I'm impatient I know the audience
is impatient too but that's just stuff
we have to do yes okay today we are
talking about two murders that took
place in the 1940s yeah I don't know
anything about these so I'm just I'm
riding along just like I'm you yeah and
these are quite I mean these are pretty
well known murder still to this day just
because they were so creepy and like I
said they're sort of related in the
sense that they happened only about 50
miles apart they happened you know a
couple years apart and because the
motive for them was sometimes seen to
have been something to do with
witchcraft one more than the other the
first one we're going to talk about is
the case that's popularly known as who
put Bella in the wood shell what's a
wood Jim it's a tree it's a temperature
and that is a bone of contention because
I read a lot of sorts because like I
said I researched this case for my book
the faceless villain and this kind of a
bone of contention because even though
popularly the tree was said to have been
a witch Elm it's actually some sources
say it was actually a witch hazel tree
not that it really matters but you know
which help sounds cooler I guess but so
basically this is what happened it was a
Sunday morning it was April 18th 1943
World War two was in full swing and
there was a bit of wood in the English
Midlands and it was owned by was part of
the estate of a gent named Lord Cobham
and it's called Hagley wood and he had
like this really large estate now on
this particular day there were four boys
teenagers and they were coaching in the
woods they were looking for birds nests
for whatever reason and so they were
kind of poking around in the woods
looking for a good tree to find the
bird's nest so they find this witch Elm
or witch hazel tree whichever it is and
they said that looks like a good place
for there to be some bird's nest that we
could collect - one of the boys
Bob farmer who was 15 climbed up the
tree to see what he could see so while
he's up there he peers down into the
hollow of the tree and sees what at
first he thinks is an animal skull so he
thinks neato
and he pulls it out except guess what
it's not an animal skull it's a human
skull and it's still got hair on
there now how high up was he when he
found this it didn't really say so I
don't think it was super high up so the
hole that he wheeshed into was in the
top of the trunk somehow yeah or the
degree was broken off or something I'm
not really they're not really sure they
didn't we're real sister yeah it was
epic so it wasn't a case where somebody
climbed a tree and then just slid down
and fell into the trunk and couldn't get
out no I don't see how that would have
happened ed any so they were dead when
they went in yeah they were dead when
they went in the tree yeah because I
imagine if it was something that simple
than it would have the case who had just
been dismissed as it acted it well yeah
so that's okay well now we're getting
into oh I'll get get ahead yeah you're
always like jumping out I gotta get a
William a man and that's how man yeah
trying to think in a mechanical way we
don't know anything about the case yet I
know that hahaha so stop assuming okay I
did okay I'm gonna check my testosterone
so at first like the boys you know he
pulls out the skull and they're like
holy [ __ ] you guys that's a human skull
right but then they thought well we're
technically not supposed to be in these
woods because it's not our property so
we're just going to keep this on the DL
so they put the skull back in the tree
and then they answer a yeah well luckily
for history one of the boys the youngest
he felt a little bad about it and then
that evening he told his dad hey Dad we
were poaching in the woods and we found
a skull in a tree so the dad called the
police
now the police went out to the woods the
next day and found the tree in the tree
aside from the skull was also an entire
skeleton except for one of the hands now
the hand was found outside of the tree
kind of scattered like in some
underbrush it was buried a little bit
now the skeleton was you know when they
examined it it was clearly that of a
woman a rather small woman she's only
about five feet tall presumably this
woman was not English I believe they
could tell just because of some of the
things that she had on her but like her
clothing and things like that she was
wearing a gold wedding ring or rather a
gold wedding ring was found with the
skeleton and a few various other things
were found shoes and stuff also there
was a pea
of taffeta stuffed into the mouth what
is it tab it's a piece of material
fabric it's kind of like that fabric
that they make poofy prom dresses and
stuff okay so they presumed that this is
how she would killed it she was
suffocated by having this habit of
crammed into her mouth they also noted a
few other things her teeth were very
crooked you know which they hopes would
make her easy to identify and various
other sayings so the taffeta in the
mouth was the only obvious injury to the
body so like I said they assumed that
that's how she had been killed
the pathologist also made a note that
it's like she must have been stuffed
into the tree pretty soon after she was
killed because if rigor mortis has ended
she wouldn't have fit they grew up
apparently ma cherie sera yeah while she
was still limped so she had been stuffed
into this tree very shortly after she
was murdered taking into account the
fact that she had these specific teeth
that were very unusual
they've started combing all the dental
records in the area and trying to match
them up with various missing persons
records from around the area no match
nothing came up now they presumed that
this woman had had some dental work
about a year prior to her death I could
guess I could tell that from the skull
but again they found no dental surgeries
in the area that would have done it or
had any record of her of the x-rays or
anything like that and you have to
imagine too that you know this was in
the middle of World War two it was
rationing there were air raids there all
kind of things going on there were
people coming and going you know so
after a while since they hadn't been
able to identify her the case goes cold
oh I forgot to mention too that from the
pathology report they determined that
the woman had actually been in the tree
for about 18 months so she's been dead
for about a year and a half okay
like I said they had had no idea who she
was about a year and a half after the
skeleton was found there appeared a
strange piece of graffiti on a wall in a
nearby town and this graffiti read who
put Bella down the witch Elm Hagley wood
what so police Hagley wood was the name
of the forest the body was found
era and the witch l must attack the tree
away now they had no idea if whoever
wrote this weird piece of graffiti
actually knew who this woman was because
they didn't know who the woman was they
didn't know if her name was Bella that
was her real name or whatever made it a
French or if this was just some person
that was making things up but because
this seemed so specific they thought
they had better investigate and you know
that maybe there was something Judas
maybe that was her name and this
graffiti turned up in various other
places too sometimes sometimes it said
who put Lua Bela down the witch helm you
know it was always variations of that
kind of thing right and they were and it
looked like the same person who wrote it
but they weren't really sure and they
never did find the person that was
writing it from this there emerged three
distinct possibilities the first
possibility was that this was simply a
prostitute a prostitute from Birmingham
came forward in 1944 and told the police
that there had been a prostitute who
went by the name of Bella that used to
work the streets around Hagley wood and
stuff like that and had kind of
disappeared sometime around 1941 police
did investigate this possibility and
nothing really came of that the second
possibility which is kind of relevant to
the topic of the show we're talking
about is that folklorist Margaret Murray
who was quite famous made much of the
fact that Bella's hand was found
separately from the rest of her body
now she thought that this might imply
that whoever had killed her was had
children some sort of a cult ritual like
they like they were making a hand of
glory which I'm not sure if you guys
probably know what that was if you
listen to that show if you're listening
to the show you probably know what and
of course but it was given you know go
see The Wicker Man they have one of
those in there but it's a you know it's
basically a hand they make out of a
corpse and you know they use it they
usually use it to get in and out of
people's houses without being seen
that's that's the spell anyway so um so
yeah Margaret Murray thought it was
pretty weird that the hand had been
found separate from the body which does
seem kind of weird I mean I guess an
animal could have done it but why just
that one hand
you know I mean so for a long time the
witchcraft thing because of the hand was
kind of the only thing going like a lot
of people seemed yeah it must have been
that and then there was all this weird
graffiti and all this other stuff so it
seemed kind of mystical and stuff like
that however many years later I believe
is in 1953 a third possibility presented
itself they were still they were still
trying to investigate this murder well
yeah because what ended up happening is
just like because like I said the case
went cold the woman was never identified
but every now and then more graffiti
would turn up which would kind of raise
more interest in the case and then
people would kind of go back and
investigate and things like that so in
1953 there was a letter received and
this letter was from a woman named una
masa and she claimed that her husband
Jack who was dead now in 1953 had worked
in a munitions factory during the war in
the Midlands now Jack masa had
apparently known this Dutch man and this
Dutch man had was a Nazi spy and he had
given Jack a whole bunch of money so
Jack would give some information about
the munitions factories in the
Birmingham area and giving it to the
Nazis and stuff like that now Jack
claimed that one day he had been meeting
this Dutch guy at a pub or something
like that that was his connection and
the Dutch guy had a woman with him who
was also Dutch and that at some point
the man and the woman began to argue and
the Dutch man strangled the woman and
then Jack said that he and the Dutch man
had gone to Hagley wood and stuffed the
woman inside the tree now subsequently
according to Jack's wife and like I said
Jack was dead at this point
this was his wife claiming that he had
said all this according to his wife Oona
Jack had had to be institutionalized
later on because he kept having
recurring nightmares about a woman
staring at him from a tree hmm right
yeah so what this was investigated now
whether or not it was true or not no one
really knows but it sounds well
the Nazi spy angle is actually fairly
plausible like I know it sounds weird
but it was the middle of World War two
several Nazi spies had been captured in
this particular area I mean the English
Midlands that was where a lot of the
munitions factories were so the Germans
would have been parachuting in there and
a couple of them did get caught
parachuting in there because they were
trying to get information about the
munitions or so where they get bombed
and things like that also there were a
couple possibilities - there was a woman
who was supposedly a Dutch Nazi spy who
had parachuted into the area sometime
around 1941 when the woman in the tree
was supposed to have died and she went
by the code name Clara Bella there was
also a possibility that she could have
been a Dutch woman named Clara Bella
Drucker's who was a known Nazi spy and
in fact another spy a male spy who also
had the last name of dronkers was
actually executed in England in 1942 I
believe there was also a few years later
they captured a Gestapo agent
he was a Czech and his name is Joseph
Jacob when he was captured they found a
picture on his person of his girlfriend
who was a german actress and cabaret
singer named Clara bowerly which could
be seen as Clarabelle or Clara Bella and
she was apparently a Nazi spy and she
was his connection there this did kind
of seem it did seem like maybe it could
have been her because she has some kind
of fucked-up look and sees - just like
the woman in the tree and also it's said
that after 1941 no one ever in Germany
ever saw her again because she was kind
of well-known like in the cabaret scene
and sort of like that and they said you
know she never had me albums come out
after that time or she never you know
whatever so they don't know if that was
really her but it does seem like a
possibility the only thing that's kind
of against that is that the skeleton
they found in the tree they think was
only about five feet tall now Clara
barelly was supposed to be quite a bit
taller than that so they're not really
sure but like
said the witchcraft angle was kind of
like the first thing and that was mostly
because of the hand the Nazi spy thing
even though there's not a great deal of
evidence to support that either it seems
like a more likely scenario just because
although I have to say if she really
wasn't not stood by and she was killed
by other Nazi spies for whatever reason
because she was messing up their mission
because who knows but why would they
take her body out to this remote English
field basically or English Forest which
maybe they didn't even know the area
that well and then stuff her in a tree
like kind of climb up a tree suffer and
surely why would they use it well just
because she was a spy does it mean it
would be legal a killer no I know that
but I mean it seems like a lot of
trouble to go well there they were
trying to hide the murder you know maybe
the guy the killer didn't know she was a
German spy yeah yeah did you kill her
for other me for other reasons yeah it
just it seemed like such a weird sort
like to me it seems like is there
probably was some Nazi connection but
the weird thing too is that there might
have been some kind of cover-up because
the body was lost the skeleton was lost
and the autopsy report one convenient
like maybe somebody in the British
intelligence agencies knew who knew who
she was
maybe they didn't want to want to come
out but it I get I guarantee the death
was probably accidental per say it was a
murder wasn't some word about a
government yeah because it didn't seem
like an assassination it seemed more
like I mean stuffing fabric into
someone's sword and suffocating them
that seems more like a crime of passion
that yea the nation even I the
government wants you dead so especially
back in those days you just get
disappeared you never hear no file yeah
no one ever knows about material but the
strange thing whatever one or they have
a show trial and everyone knows about it
you know yeah that's true regardless of
whether she was just a random prostitute
that got murdered whether she was killed
in some weird occult ceremony or whether
she was a Nazi spy who was killed Friday
then a really a doubt the occult angle
the whole hand thing that's coincidence
it may be a maybe the way the body was
stuffed in the tree the hand was more
towards the opening and then an animal
grabbed it and hid word or a
decomposition of cell wall happened
rain came in it roll or a little while
and you know some of the numbers in that
room and really I mean the only reason
that I think that the occult angle
gained so much steam not only because it
was Margaret Murray saying it's because
like I said she's quite a famous so
forth but also because of the next
murder we're going to talk about which
actually seemed a lot more like a
witchcraft or a cult type murder so I
think that the two cases became
associated even though they might not be
but that area of England I mean the
Midlands of England there was like a lot
of custody witchcraft II wasn't sure
because there were a lot of people that
had those kind of superstitions still
even in the 1940s I mean the thing about
the bail in the which Elm case is that
one never solved they still don't know
who that woman is they still unknown
killed her or why and the weird thing
too is that every now and then you still
get some of that graffiti there's like
an others like a stone obelisk may have
a beard I mean that's what I was
thinking that it was kind of like a
Kilroy Was here should have been saying
where people are just going around like
I'm putting that up on this on the thing
because and especially now that the case
is there prevalent on the Internet
sure that I think a lot of people got
interested as so kind of revived the
whole the whole Bil'in the witch Elm
graffiti yeah so actually we're getting
to the halfway point right now so let's
take a break and then when we come back
we're going to talk about another way
more witch crafty type murder
so you were just you anyone go with it
yeah so the next we're going to talk
about is the Charles Walton murder known
as the pitchfork murder or the
witchcraft murder this one this one's
actually kind of a tree
alright so we'll be back in just a few
minutes how do people who make stuff up
for a living make stuff up New York
Times best seller Jonathan Mayberry told
us Oh
[Music]
Oprah's Book Club favorite sue Miller
Tomo do you sort of take a character and
make some bad things happen have we get
them to do that we colored them just
like at a cocktail party except to your
headphone join us every Thursday for the
buyers club odd cat a slightly unhinged
podcast where storytellers interview
other storytellers available on project
Entertainment Network iTunes and
everywhere podcast - heard subculture
corsets in clothing is our favorite
store for unusual clothing shoes and
accessories they offer a wide selection
of men's and women's clothing at great
prices so culture also offers the cool
selection
of shoes and accessories steampunk
gothic apparel retro corsets and so much
more at subculture corsets and clothing
check out subculture online at
subculture corsets calm that subculture
corsets calm make sure you use the
discount code 13 o'clock for a 10%
discount subculture corsets calm or
visit their store in Jacksonville
Florida just off i-95 is on its pasand
Buzard Weir's the coupon head posted by
me
mr. Frank the song is the Toki's podcast
with Azzaro
fiction genre and those are right weird
and read weird are going to love this
box will be anyone and the bizarre and
weird quick thrill so join us here every
Monday presented exclusively by project
and for teaming
you
Tina clock fans love the show but don't
have an hour to spare check out our new
list Channel 13 o'clock in minutes all
the fun creepy topics of the main
podcast but in easy to swallow
bite-sized pieces
links in the description more videos to
come soon
[Music]
[Music]
you
okay and we're back talking about
witchcraft murders this is another quite
famous unsolved murder and this one has
a lot more witchcraft II details as I
said this took place on Valentine's Day
1945 and this was in Warwickshire very
near to Shakespeare country only a few
miles from Stratford upon even a lot of
legends around that area like I said a
lot of druid types should all this kind
of stuff which kind of contributed to
for this case kind of being associated
with that so it's Valentine's Day and
there's a 74 year old man he's a farm
laborer and his name is Charles Walton
he has lived his entire life in the
village of lower Quinton he lives in a
small cottage with his niece Edith
Walton who he adopted when she was three
years old after her mother died he heads
off to work that he does every day he
leaves the house at 8 a.m. 4:00 p.m.
comes around
Edith comes home and her uncle is not
there now she starts to worry because he
is a creature of habit and so she rounds
up a couple friends and the farmer that
he that Charles Walton had been working
for Alfred Potter and says you know
let's go look for him so they go out to
the farm where he had been cutting some
hedges that day underneath an oak tree
they find his body he has been bashed in
the head with his own walking stick his
throat had been slashed and some
accounts say that he had a cross drawn
on his chest with a billhook which is
like a it's like a scythe kind of bang
like a fixed-size
also his body has been pinned to the
ground by his own pitchfork obviously
this seems a little strange the
pitchfork had been embedded into the old
guy's body so severely but it took two
big burly guys to pull it out man it had
gone like all the way through him all
the way through his flesh bone all the
way into the ground with six inches so
immediately rumors started to circulate
around town small town less than five
hundred people the Charles Walton had
been the victim of an evil I murder some
kind of
black magic visual no good it's also
important to note that that near when a
body was found in an area called Mian
hill and Mian Hill has for many
centuries been considered to be a place
of druidic sacrifice apparently there's
a tree that grows there that was like a
witching tree where like you know covens
would come and have meetings and stuff
like that some people also found it
suspicious that the murder had taken
place on Valentine's Day which in the
old calendar correspond to Candlemas or
the Celtic Festival of Imbolc
which if I'm pronouncing that correctly
Bravo wina but apparently that was kind
of a date when you would do sacrifices
to kind of you know nourish the land and
I leave it like that
now at first I mean when the police came
and they even this murder was so strange
that they even got chief inspector
Robert Fabian who is actually quite
famous they actually made a TV show or
radio show about him later on called
Fabian of the yard he's from Scotland
Yard and he actually came to investigate
now him and all the other investigators
they interviewed all 493 residents of
the town of lower Quentin and at the
time they said that the town's folks
seemed very reticent they didn't really
want to talk to the police they seemed
very I don't know if they seemed so
secretive but they were just kind of
like yeah we don't know what he's saying
we don't want to talk I kind of paint in
a wicker man type situation yeah it
definitely did come across that way
although at first I don't think Robert
Fabian was really down with the whole
witchcraft thing at first until one of
the other investigators handed him this
book and the book was called folklore
old customs and superstitions in
Shakespeare land and it kind of talked
about the area of Warwickshire and how
you know going back centuries that there
are all these kind of you know legends
associated with this particular area
near where the body was found and he
also pointed out that described in this
book there was another murder that took
place 70 years before it had a lot
parallel with the Charles Walton murder
now according to this book it said that
there was a woman named Ann Turner she
was 80 years old and has happened in
1875 she has lived in the town of lower
Quintin apparently someone else in the
town and James Heywood who was kind of a
simpleton let's put it like that kind of
a village idiot sucka he started to
believe that Ann Turner was a witch and
that she had cast an evil eye over the
town that had made all these cattle died
and made crops fail and things like that
and James Heywood evidently killed and
Taylor by pinning her to the ground with
a pitchfork and carving a cross into her
body now this didn't happen on any kind
of anniversary of that murder did it no
okay so like I said but if it happened
on a significant date in the in that in
the occult calendar I guess you could
say he also pointed out that there had
been a lot of you know kind of
witchcraft legends associated with that
area
and probably one of the most famous ones
was that of like phantom black dogs
right there's like all these black dogs
seen around this area of man hell right
so we tend in this particular book and
because the murder of Charles Walton was
seen as extensively similar to that to
the murder of Ann Turner several years
before so they started to look at the
witchcraft angle now they did note that
there had been some things going on in
lower Quentin that might have inspired
this type of thing the crops had failed
the year before the farmers that Charles
Wilson was working for his some of his
cattle had died so maybe some of the
town's book started believable maybe
somebody for some reason blames Charles
Walden or thought he was a witch and so
sauce they would take care of it and use
him as a sort of sacrifice because they
said the way that he was found as a way
that he was murdered would have caused
like his blood flowing to the ground
stuff like that which is a very you know
a cult type of thing to do there was
also the matter of me on Hill being
you know associated with witchcraft and
stuff were probably led 2,000 years
one of the main legends about this area
is out of the Phantom black dogs now in
this book that the investigator showed
to Fabian there was also a story about a
young boy who was walking around the
area and on three consecutive nights or
on several consecutive nights he was
passed by a black dog which is
supposedly a harbinger of death and on
the third night that the boy saw his dog
the dog either turned into a headless
woman or a headless woman like appeared
next to the black dog and the little boy
ran home freaked out and then discovered
that his sister had died yeah
now it should be noted that the little
boy in this legend was named Charles
Walton just like the guy who was
murdered okay so a lot of people thought
well maybe that with him as a kid you
know what I mean so maybe there's some
kind of connection there
there are also legends that Robert
Fabian the chief investigator that he
also saw black dogs in the area running
around like after the murder when he was
investigating it and some sources say
that he found a black dog hanging in a
tree near where the body was found so
really they didn't have a lot of leads
one person said oh they saw this man
near where there was look like he was
washing blood off they did catch that
guy he was an Italian guy he was a
prisoner of war
and he was from a nearby Pio WKF which
was actually not so much a PW prison as
it was just a place where people say
it's because they could water around
again grows or whatever minimum-security
yeah it was a minimum-security so this
guy had apparently and he'd been out
poaching for food and when they tested
the blood that they found on it was
radically so his story checked out so
wasn't it there were also rumors that
maybe Charles Walton's planned George
Higgins had killed him but you know not
really a motive George Higgins was an
old man so they didn't really think he
was going around doing that kind of show
unlikely than the old guys yeah unlikely
robbery also unlikely Charles Walton
didn't
a lot of money and the money that he did
have was still in his house so really
the only other suspect was the man that
Charles Walton had been working for
Alfred Potter who was a farmer now there
were a couple sketchy things about
Potter when he was I mean he was one of
the people that initially found the body
him and Edith and liked one other person
when the police got there he was
actually gonna leave before the police
arrived
but then the police arrived just as he
was leaving because he was kind of like
yeah what a Requested [ __ ] but now the
police said he was acting a little
strange he was complaining about being
cold he seemed very nervous he made a
point of saying that if they found his
fingerprints on the murder weapons it
was because he had touched them while he
was checking to see if Charles Walton
was still alive which seemed a little
weird the police didn't find any
fingerprints on the murder weapon but
you know they just thought it was
strange that he made a point of saying
that I don't know it's kind of hours
down yeah
also he kind of had a couple different
stories about what he was doing that day
like right around the time when Charles
Walton would have died like at first he
said oh I was at a pub with two of my
employees and then another time he said
oh I was checking on this heifer that
was wounded or something like that so
you know he kind of came up with
different stories different alibis about
what he was doing that day you know that
happen yeah that's what I mean you know
at some point detectives not very
specific about what time it was
Yeah right so the story changed a couple
times but it wasn't anything that was
like super ingredient right yeah and the
thing is that really even though he was
really the only likely suspect they had
because they have no idea who else it
could have been there was really no
reason for him to have done it I mean
here's the thing they thought oh well
maybe they had a fight but no one they
were all evidence of that they said oh
maybe there was some kind of scam going
are they were fighting about wages the
only thing weird that turned up about
that was that Alfred Potter
apparently reported more wages than he
actually paid to Charles Walton and then
you would pocket the difference right so
really he was benefit
from Charles Walton being alive and
being working for him because he was
making extra money by saying I'm paying
him more you know it doesn't sound like
he killed it
so yeah and so like I said it really
didn't seem like he had any reason
shamera
even though he acted kind of sketchy and
stuff like that so despite all the
investigation that they did they went on
for a really long day took a boot prints
they interviewed thousands of people
they had all the best minds on it from
Scotland Yard and stuff like that never
saw no arrests were ever made really no
other than Potter really no serious
suspect Russ and they kind of thought
and especially after when the kind of
witchcraft [ __ ] about this came out like
I said him being killed on Valentine's
Day it also happened to be Ash Wednesday
which was also kind of a big city or a
date and you know the way he was killed
the place he was killed so I think
people did kind of maybe associate it
with witchcraft but no one in the town
would really give it up if somebody did
kill him thinking he was a witch because
there were rumors evidently some people
in town thought he was a witch like he
raised toads and meant the toes there
were people filled if I don't know if he
really did that but there were like
rumors so it could have been that
someone in the town thought he was to
blame for the previous year's crop
failure or for whatever reason and just
decided to go out it just seems weird to
me that it happened in like broad
daylight it was like the middle of a day
know what it sounds like to me was that
that case it happened in Russia with the
three teenagers just ran around killing
random people yeah that's right I
remember though what what is the name of
that case do you remember no I don't
just kind of remind you of that like
something that just a couple of
teenagers own around pages do yeah yeah
there's runkis here that look at that
old man let's go it you know then they
run off yeah I could back it up it
could've just be something as simple and
random that yeah it just seems like a
labor-intensive way of killing someone
yeah well it seemed ritually well if you
look up to that if you look at the
videos that those Russian kids took
they're enjoying it
they're you know throwing bricks on guys
you know that's crushing them with the
single refrigerator
yeah not gonna refrigerator on the guy
and then throwing bricks on his head and
they were just laughing having a good
time you know Nancy and hitting with a
hammer I think it's a long times I've
seen it
but they had that video week on the
Internet yeah I remember the thing
though about this is that there's a lot
of myth and legend surrounding the case
that maybe make it more or less likely
that it was a witchcraft murder I think
it might have been it might have had
that kind of aspect like I said just
because of that area at the time there
was so much superstition in that vein
that it wouldn't have been crazy for
someone to have murdered someone in that
way now it should be noted that the
previous murder of the woman and Turner
which had taken place seventy years
before was not as similar as it appeared
on first blush now she was killed
because someone in the village thought
she was a witch and she was killed with
a pitchfork
she wasn't pinned to the ground she
didn't have a cross or anything like
that
she was actually killed in full view of
many other villagers the guy that killed
her was like I said he was kind of a
village idiot and he became convinced
that her witchcraft had caused the crops
to fail so he was drunk one night and
just came at her with a pitchfork and
stabbed her and she died later and so
and and there were numerous witnesses
who had happened like in the middle of
the street so he was later put into a
lunatic asylum now there was also the
story about the kid with the black dog
and how that might have been the same
Charles Walden probably not I mean one
that's a pretty common name to the dates
would have been about right but you know
the whole fulcrum of the story was that
these black dogs were court ending the
death of his sister he did have three
sisters but they all lived so they said
unless his mom had some sister that died
that no one knew about then that
probably wasn't the same guy it should
be noted too that there is speculation
that Charles Walton might be related to
Ann Turner in some way but she is his
great-grandson or is you know somewhat
distantly related so they're not real
sure about that but it's possible also I
think that at the time when Robert
Fabian was talking about the case and he
was I mean as skeptical as he was he was
you know the main guy from Scotland Yard
and all this he was quite famous as
I'm and he seemed to at first think the
whole witchcraft angle was you know a
bunch of hooey but I think the more he
looked into it the more convinced he
became about that angle though he never
could solve it all that being said I
think that some of the stuff he said
about the town spoke being secretive or
not when I talking was maybe a little
exaggerated it could be that the town
spoke didn't really talk to him or
didn't really tell him because maybe
they didn't know anything you know what
I mean it might not have been just them
being [ __ ] or trying to stonewall
because they were covering up or
something like maybe they did just
really didn't know what was going on and
they I mean they definitely did they
definitely did seem like superstitious
people some of them did actually believe
in witchcraft and believe in the evil
eye and that kind of stuff so like I
said it is possible that one of their
number had killed the guy but it's also
possible that a lot of them didn't know
who it was
you know and they were from a small town
they were they didn't trust outsiders
well and things like that so there might
not have been as much to that as it
seems like so whether I don't know it's
like so whether that was the case I kind
of feel like you know in the both cases
we talked about like I said I wanted to
do both of them on one show not just
because I just worked on my book but
also because you know they both kind of
had different motivation where they
could have been at witchcraft murder I
mean the first one I don't think it was
I definitely think that was probably
more likely to be a Nazi spies have to
say but the second one definitely sounds
ritualistic to me I mean if somebody
just wanted that old guy dead then just
hit them on the head with a cane would
have done the trick I kind of disagree I
think it was something like crazy
teenagers really yeah I think that they
killed him that fun with it they got
away with it that's correct
something like that I don't know this
does seem kind of like I don't know it
just seems so specific the way he was
kind of like I said it's hard to tell
now because so much legend and rumor
surrounds the case like I said some
sources say that he had a cross carvings
chest
some sources says wasn't there
her gifts had a third flash you look at
just demographics crime demographic
specially from today and actually
throughout history a lot of these
murders into high propensity of it is
hyper portion of it is actually crazy
teenage men create a teenage boys they
do a lot of it and it sounds something
like that maybe they thought he was a
witch yeah because like I said I don't
think that's [ __ ] I do think people
there might have believed that whether
that was justified and I don't know if
he acted weird he didn't really seem
like he was particularly hated in the
town but I guess there were rumors
swirling around because it didn't take
long after he got murdered for some of
the town spoke to be like oh he got
killed because of witchcraft because he
killed the crops last year I just got a
feelings a couple of teenage boys just
[ __ ] around yam is a size of which
hate we're going to take him out yeah
something like that
and they oh yeah because maybe maybe
they heard their parents talking about I
better do that Charles welcome guy yeah
always like with the toads and every day
yeah themselves you know well yeah maybe
we do we get in there you take care of
that yeah yeah I think it something like
that I love that it's like I don't love
the people that murdered like that but I
I'm always kind of like that's why I
like movies like The Wicker Man all and
I love that folklore was that old druid
sacrifice type [ __ ] none of this stuff
happens in a vacuum
you know once you understand everything
behind it like if you know when you look
at murders that are solved and then
they're you know you look at everything
behind them you know all the motivations
involved all the characters and the
people involved they're kind of
understandable yeah they're a little bit
more understandable you thinking
something really wacky once you know to
the serial killer stuff when you
understand how screwed up a lot of
serial killers are you understand what
it is we'll see them justify it but you
write you and actually that's what kind
of interest me about them it's like once
you understand how their mind works yes
you understand how they came to the
conclusions that they can do why they
why they went with the actions they went
with obviously you're not justifying it
no and a lot of times there's nothing
really mysterious about these guys you
know I mean like they're not Hannibal
Lecter's like you seen in Hollywood
they're actually pretty dumb
yeah I'm pretty mundane there's nothing
really that special about I can
understand why people are fascinated by
the chronic
but well just because it's so out of our
personal experience I mean but if you
ever look at interviews with them you
know there's not much to those guys yeah
I definitely feel like a lot of people
that are into serial killers and you
know make those guys out to be anymore
well they glamorize it to something that
I feel like they do glamorize it and
because the thing is if you see like you
said if you see interviews with a lot of
these guys they just seem like like a
pathological - love - love slash
pathological liar it's kind of guy that
you would you know if you if you just
you know saw him in a bar or something
like I think it was you know I mean
they're kind of repellant yes you know
he not cool at all doing the only one
knows that it was ever captured that was
kind of like or seen kind of like a
regular guy to me would have been Bundy
yeah ed Bundy could pass for a regular
guy yeah you'd be like he could pass for
our normal person yeah at least at first
glance probably I'm out with him long
enough he for every life is no you know
yeah there's something the matter with
that guy but yeah definitely he did he
did come across as the most normal or
member I want to excel Shane I'm just
losers yeah bad losers like yeah Charles
Ning and Leonard Lake losers
BTK yeah BTK uptight loser yeah they do
a lot of them do kind of c1 yeah Delta
who's the John Wayne Gacy the clown guy
yeah loser
yeah all those kind of figure we've done
a few shows about the one that was never
one that we're never caught like you
know zodiac yeah pretty interesting
evidence you have behind you know but
never never captured probably a loser
probably a Brienne you meeting you got
your year your zodiac damn what a
letdown
hahahahaha that's pretty sick bite okay
but you know we made you know you're
expecting some kind of yes I'm out of
the monsters about the movies yeah yeah
that's the kind of interesting yeah
that's kind of the interesting thing
about a lot of these people that see
these kind of MERS not just serial
killers but any kind of people with
these kind of bizarre gruesome murders
it's like when you don't know who it is
it seems like it's got to be some like
in the movies and rooks and
how do we scary monsters I say here then
you see it it's just some fat Baldy yeah
you're like that's a bad guy they're all
looks like the guy that works at
7-eleven yeah they're you know they're
overcompensating yeah they're trying to
compensate true is there anything else I
think that uh no I think that's not
which this is plug patreon again yes you
guys okay so that'll that'll do it for
this episode we have to enjoy this
rather rambling discussion don't forget
to check out our patreon please please
please go check our patreon patreon that
we've got a really cool page latch 13
o'clock podcast we've got a really cool
patreon pitch video up there so you see
us and like I said there are a couple of
patreon only posts that we put up there
in the last few days like I said one of
them was like a half hour thing of us
talking about cheesy music documentaries
and the other one was me reading a
section of my upcoming true crime book
the faceless villain so Dan Veronica MS
there's stuff there's a new material up
there on patreon which I guess yes you
want to check it out and we'll probably
and I'm going to be putting some more up
there a couple days we're going to I'm
going to do one of the some of the
horror movies and all all kind of
thoughts ever so I'm going to try and
put new stuff up every couple days so
definitely go check that out check out
projects entertainment network they have
a patreon also it's at patreon.com slash
project Antonette go subscribe to our 13
o'clock in minutes video channel and
watch the new video that i just put up
and you know as usual like subscribe
below check out zazzle.com slash 13
o'clock and then we'll see you got our
t-shirts and we will see you guys in a
couple days next Tuesday
[Music]
you
[Music]
you